[Applause]  [Music]  that's the single man come to see me  Tara's Miglin I'm arresting you for the  murder of Frankie Petersen for the wife  [Music]  I'm he's baffled by this conflicting  evidence as you are his prints are all  over the crime scene the TV footage but  some 60 miles away we can have been the  two places at once you know me I didn't  kill that kid ro do you see how strange  it  what would make someone do such a thing  he didn't do it I have no tolerance for  the unexplainable bullet sir you'll have  no tolerance for me  answer me this do you think Terry matron  killed that boy  if he didn't do it someone else dead  someone else  [Music]  jessa  [Music]  you